a lot of people are asking what would  Dolly do and here's why country music  legend Dolly Parton was just awarded 100  million dollars by Amazon founder Jeff  Bezos he named Parton the winner of the  2022 courage and civility award check  out her reaction  people are in a position to help  to help and I know that I've always said  I try to put my money where my heart is  and  all the money will be donated to charity  of Dolly's choice no word yet on how she  plans to give away the money but we know  it's going to be good she's a big  supporter of child literacy yeah one of  her big philanthropic efforts no she's  philanthropic everybody wants to be  Dolly Parton so there's Jeff Bezos his  partner Lauren Sanchez she had no idea  it was coming I know no idea and no  strings we love you Dolly